[Musique] étrangère
non seulement vous avez les épées qui
sont intactes et si vous regardez attentivement,
certaines d'entre elles n'ont même pas la
patine et elles sont encore tranchantes et
c'est spécial à des degrés divers que vous pouvez
réellement voir le fait qu'elles étaient
aiguisés par une pierre qui est évidente
ici mais certains d'entre eux ont été trouvés dans
des fourreaux qui sont intacts que vous avez
le bois que vous avez le cuir
normalement des choses comme ça périssent
oh
[Musique]
il y a quelques allusions à chaque épée qui
raconte une histoire différente  à
qui appartenait ce placard, qui a changé le bout de cette
armoire et y a ajouté une ficelle faite de tendons
et de cuir et c'est toute sa beauté,
donc nous ne regardons pas seulement les artefacts,
nous essayons en fait de voir que les
gens qui s'y trouvent sont morts maintenant,
mais j'espère  nous pourrons raconter
leur histoire
[Musique]
merci